Keep on rockin, Timme!
Wir können ja nicht aufhören, bevor hier nicht Gras durch die Seidenstraße kommt.
Da hinten sind noch Wundertüten für uns.
Noch eine.
Riesen Wundertüten. Kannst du mal eine aufmachen.
Tolle Überraschung.
Ja, wir geben was dabei.
Na gut, eine mach ich auf, wenn da kein Gras drin ist.
Dann streike ich hier.
Ein Förmchen, ah, für so viel Sand und keine Förmchen.
Hab ich euch schon gesagt, dass dieses MacBook Air einfach mal der geilste Computer, der es überhaupt gibt?
Ja, gleich nach meinem.
Ich meine, mit diesen ganzen Retina-Hips dann kannst du mich ja jagen.
Hier guck mal, eine 2D-Brille.
Ja, für den nächsten Kinobesuch.
Ich habe auch keine Retina, aber ich habe noch einen richtigen Computer mit Ethernet und so.
Ich habe Schwein gehabt.
Ich habe einen Nashorn und einen Wolf.
Ich habe ein Fußballspiel, das ist geil. Ein Fußballflipper habe ich hier.
Und ich habe eine Lupe, endlich kann ich wieder was lesen auf meinem Bildschirm.
20 habe ich.
Dennis, du mit Alkohol, dass ich das noch erleben darf.
Und Knusperl, das ist geil.
Kommt ihr nächstes Mal mit zur Union?
Union was?
Wenn wir wieder gewinnen.
Erste FC-Union in Berlin, wir haben zweimal gewonnen.
Christdemokratische?
Nee, nee, eine richtige Union.
Wer von euch ist aus Berlin?
Hälfte, was?
Und wer geht zur Union?
Naja, immerhin auch niemand.
Wer geht überhaupt zu Fußball? What is this Fußball anyway?
Ich sag dir, das Wissen um Fußball ist sozusagen noch eine gesellschaftliche Weiterentwicklungsstufe, die diese Szene auch durchaus noch mitnehmen kann.
Wenn wir so weit sind, können wir auch aufhören.
Die Nerds und Fußball, du denkst, dass das kompatibel ist? Hier, mach doch mal.
Da kommt ja immer das Gleiche. Denk doch immer was anderes aus.
Also früher auf dem Congress, ne?
Ja.
Da konnte man eine Decktelefonnummer anrufen.
Thema war Fußball.
Und dann gab es Fußballergebnisse.
Und dann gab es entweder einen Wodka-Shot oder Gras. Per Seidenstraße.
Der geht, hier.
Fußballergebnisse wäre doch mal ganz gut, oder?
Haben wir eigentlich noch Themen?
Nee, wir reden eigentlich nur noch um Kopf und Kragen. Bisher lief es ja noch ganz gut. Aber ich würde sagen jetzt...
Mit steigendem Alkoholfegel bei Herrn Ahrens und Herrn Roddy.
Noch mal feige.
Also ich...
Ihr dürft wieder abstimmen.
Wir können ja noch irgendwie...
Wer trinkt den? Selber? Ist ja einfach.
Wir können ja einfach auch Schluss machen.
Ich hab noch was. Hast du in den letzten Jahren, sagen wir so vor 5 und vorher, die haben sich immer beschwert, so der Frauenanteil stimmt hier irgendwie nicht richtig. Kannst du dir erinnern? Das war noch vor den ganzen Creeper-Cards und weiß-ich-nicht-alles. Kannst du dir erinnern? Naja, klar. Und hat sich noch mal wer beschwert dieses Jahr? Ist das noch Thema? Was schätzt du, was der Anteil ist?
Also ich kenn Stimmen, die sagen, der Frauenanteil wäre schon zu hoch, aber... Aber ich sag keine Namen.
Aber lass mich raten, es war eine Frau.
Ich sag keine Namen.
Aber wir sind auf einem Level angekommen, wo man sagen kann, es ist ungefähr, weil die perfekten 50 Prozent gibt's natürlich nicht, aber ich denke mal, es ist jetzt, man kann sagen, es ist okay.
Warum nicht?
Er hat ja auch getrunken. Das geht ja alles einher.
Aber ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen, vor 15 Jahren hättet ihr hier gesessen und ihr hättet, es wären nur Typen und vielleicht drei Frauen im ganzen Publikum. Ist so, oder?
Ja, war so.
Nur Typen auf der Bühne.
Vor der lieben Podcast, nur Typen auf der Bühne.
Wir quatschen schon wieder von dir.
Diese Stimme aus dem Off, Alter. Wir machen unsere Sendung so, wie wir wollen.
Genau, wir sind nämlich autark und autonom.
Aber, kurz schätzt. Also, tatsächlich ist es auch wie beim Camp so, dass die ganzen Leute, die ich hier wieder zum ersten Mal zum Congress geschleppt haben, dass die, das sind überwiegend leider auch Typen, muss ich zu meiner Stande gestehen, aber eine Studentin ist auch gekommen, immerhin. Aber auf jeden Fall haben die Typen auch gesagt, ja, sie wären auf jeden Fall überrascht, dass hier nicht nur Typen rumlaufen. Ich hätte ja, ich würde ja nicht 50-50 sagen, aber ich würde sagen...
Nee, hab ich nie gesagt. Ich hab auf einem Level gesagt, wo okay ist.
Aber ich würde sagen, es ist auf jeden Fall eine gute Entwicklung.
Ich hab irgendwie das Gefühl, wir sind auf dünnem Eis und irgendwie sollten wir das Gespräch nicht fortführen.
Mit beiden Beinen Fenster.
Aber ich stimme euch auf jeden Fall zu.
Wenn wir hier auf dünnem Eis sind, dann hätte die Sendung gestern mit Holger gar nicht stattfinden dürfen.
Naja, es fühlt sich normaler an.
Bitte was? Mehr über Max reden. Hab ich ja schon probiert, kam ja nicht an.
So ist ja nichts passiert, oder?
Nein, Tim wollte sein MacBook eher loben.
Hat jemand das neue Battery-Case eigentlich?
Fürs iPhone?
Keiner, okay.
Die Scheiße!
Nee, das bringt nichts. Komm, wir machen Schluss.
Ja, wir machen die Freak Show in der Lounge weiter.
Genau.
Im Club.
Genau, das machen wir.
Wir hören jetzt auf und dann spielen wir noch ein schönes Lied für euch. Und dann war's das irgendwie. Und wir bedanken uns ausgesprochen.
Komm, verneigen, verneigen. Wir verneigen uns vor unseren Hörern, denn ihr seid super.
Für die Fans. Hast du alle Knaller weggeknallt? Ah, dieser scheiß Creepy Steve immer.
Willst du's behalten?
Ja, die brauchen wir. Themenwürfel.